in the run-up to this week's united
nations session
perhaps the biggest question was would
president trump meet
with iranian president hassan rouhani to
talk about the increasing hostilities
between those two nations
so far it has not happened not likely to
happen
earlier today president trump called on
allies to intensify pressure on iran as
you just saw
tonight fox news sunday anchor chris
wallace talks exclusively
to the iranian leader mr president
you heard president trump's speech today
he said no nation
should support iran's and i quote
bloodlust
and fanatical quest for nuclear weapons
your response
i am amazed at the interpretations
of mr trump vis-a-vis terrorism
those who succeeded in syria
and in iraq to bring terrorism to an end
eradicate daesh isis with the help of
the iraqi people and the syrian people
that
was iran that was the country of iran
and the country
that is present and flying over
the airspace of and bombarding
the soil of the country of syria without
permission of the
government is the united states of
america and today america unfortunately
is the supporter of terrorism in our
region and wherever america has gone
terrorism has expanded in that in the
wake wherever we have gone on the other
side
we have defeated terrorism
one example is the ish or isis in our
region
vis-a-vis the nuclear issue we are
committed
to the non-proliferation treaty as well
as
the protocols the additional protocols
so our activities are peaceful
those who are going outside of the
framework of the npt
is the united states of america that is
against the framework of the npt
conducting nuclear
weapon tests we will get into your
contention that is the us not iran
that is the sponsor of terror in a
moment but president trump has spoken
often about being willing to meet with
you even sometimes without
preconditions what do you think are the
chances that
this week at the united nations either
in a formal setting
or perhaps as they have in these
diplomatic
sessions where you just happen to bump
into each other
that you and president trump will speak
to each other
why would we bump into one another
we seek to pursue higher goals
to benefit both countries both people it
must be planned
and talks must be based on those plans
but prior to that we must create mutual
trust
and the trust is something that mr trump
took away
from this framework we had an agreement
mr trump
exited without a valid justification and
illegally
from an international agreement if the
united states of america's
government is willing to talk
it must create the needed conditions
but it is no longer just president trump
because this week the european countries
who signed on to the iran nuclear deal
i'm talking about britain
and france and germany now say that they
agree with president trump that it was
iran that was responsible
for the saudi attack the attack on saudi
oil
facilities and like mr trump they say
iran should now agree to a bigger
new deal on nuclear weapons and
on regional stability and your missile
systems
will you
once we carried on negotiations with the
united states of america for two years
and during a 17-day period the
foreign minister of the islamic republic
of iran and the u.s secretary of state
had continuous talks
without returning to their countries it
was
extremely difficult but we did reach an
agreement
which was signed and it was enshrined in
the united nations security council
resolution and without a valid reason or
cause the united states
left this agreement so it took away the
foundation
of the needed trust i think more than
the issues
touched upon the most basic needed issue
is trust
and mr trump damaged the trust between
the two countries so this is very
important
trust must be restored and the
restoration of trust
consists in taking away
the pressure imposed upon the nation and
the people of iran
which show that clearly there is
animosity even towards our children
our ill people because we they even have
difficulty
in obtaining basic medications and
medical equipment this is a type of
terrorism this is inhumane
and if there is a cessation to this then
of course the atmosphere will change
of course then it can be envisioned then
we can talk about
many different topics of mutual interest
for both sides
just as vis-a-vis the nuclear issue
in the year 2015 we reached an agreement
we can
reach agreements on other topics as well
but it
seems for the last year and a half since
the u.s pulled out of the agreement
as if iran's policy has been to drive a
wedge
between the u.s president trump and
europe which has stood by the agreement
now this week it seems because of the
fact
that iran was responsible for this
attack on saudi oil facilities
that you have in fact united the
countries that has backfired on you
and now europe has agreed with the us
that they need to reopen new talks
avalon first
oil installations in saudi arabia that
were attacked
that returns to the saudi
attack on the country of yemen and the
khan and
the people of yemen have the inherent
right even brought in the united nations
charter
to defend themselves when they have been
the subject of bombardments for over
five years
of course the people of yemen have the
right to defend themselves
and attack but mr president
say the drones were not yemeni they were
iranian
they were delta wings and delta waves
the saudis say the cruise missiles were
not yemeni
they were iranian they were ya ali
systems
and even your closest partner in europe
french president macron seems to agree
he has agreed he says that it is iran
that was responsible
for the attack on saudi arabia
well because you are quite an
experienced reporter
mr wallace you did not allow me to
complete my previous answer
not a problem i will return
to what you were
has leveled an accusation an unfounded
accusation against iran
when the saudi arabian spokesperson
announced
that these
there are shiites in yemen as well so
that spokesperson who thinks
iranians are all shiites and yemenis are
not shiites
they are mistaken is a chant in a slogan
of aspiration
uh that is chanted in iraq in yemen in
iran
so quite frankly it is really egregious
for someone to say because of the word
for them to attribute that to iran but
let's assume if it was
from iran all of the monies received
from the united states for these
defensive systems for these weapon
systems radar systems
installed in saudi arabia and throughout
the arabian peninsula how come they were
not able
to prevent that missile from hitting the
target so what was the point of selling
all of that patriot
anti-missile system so that's
quite frankly even worse and if we
accept the u.s accusation
then it is even more embarrassing
perhaps for the united states
and they must answer as to why they were
not able to stop
and intercept the system the missile
the yemenis have quite advanced military
capabilities
so why is it that the intelligence
agencies of the united states of america
that are receiving large budgets from
the taxpayers based in the united states
why is it that they were completely
unaware of these military yemeni
capabilities
so they must be held to answer
america must answer why did it sell the
region so many systems so many weapons
so then they must answer why
have they not been able to establish
where it came from and then show the
proof of it
which radar system intercepted these
weapons
which one put a lock on a radar lock on
it as they were coming towards the
target
so if this is all proven that they must
answer why their defensive capabilities
did not suffice
and why is it that america and the
europeans have been aiding
the saudi arabians and their partners in
conducting daily killings of the people
of yemen so those
who share in the bloodshed of the yemeni
people have no right to make such
unfounded expressions and last night in
my meeting with mr macron i asked him
why do you say that iran is responsible
he said our technical experts
have said that the yemenis have not yet
reached that type of technical
capability
advanced technical capability and in
response i told them that you are
unaware
of their capabilities so if there is no
ceasefire
moving forward you will see once again
and you will witness
the military capabilities of the yemeni
so
let's come together and find a solution
leveling unfounded accusations are not
constructive let's help the people of
yemen and not
let them continue let's not let the
saudis continue the daily bombings peace
is a much more attainable beneficial
place to go
rather than attributing accusations at
one another
you talk about coming together and in
fact you are bringing to the u.n
a new peace plan called hope the hormoz
peace endeavor but there are many
nations
in the region that say that iran is the
last country
that should be proposing peace since may
they say you have mined tankers in the
persian gulf
you have seized a british ship you have
shot down a united states drone
and now the saudi oil attack
they say an iranian peace plan
is like putting the fox in charge of the
hen house
iran in iran
over 17 000 innocent civilians are now
living
their lives under your auspices here in
the united states of america and mr
bolton who uh
up until not too long ago was your
national security adviser was on their
payroll
giving speeches on their behalf so iran
is a country that has brought
peace in the region excuse me sir and i
say this respectfully
you have given hundreds of millions
perhaps a billion dollars to hezbollah
to hamas to various groups that is not a
support of terrorism
you label people who fight for the
defense of their country and their lands
as terrorism
so those who are the subjects of
occupation what should they do
be passive and just look you call the
people in yemen who are defending their
countries terrorists
and those who make the bombs and the
missiles and the weapon systems and then
make them readily available to the saudi
arabians with which to target school
buses schools and weddings and hospitals
you do not find them guilty do you say
why did you shoot down an american drone
but i asked you why did you bring down
a civilian airliner in which you killed
over 290 civilian passengers if we
defended we defended our territory our
country
but why is the united states present in
our region
why did the united states brought down a
civilian airliner
that's true and it was a terrible
terrible
act act and many years ago but we're
talking about hamas we're talking about
hezbollah
we're talking about firing missiles
under civilian areas
we're talking about blowing up people
in in civilian areas of israel that's
not terrorism
you defend in israel sir the foundation
of which is based upon attacking
and usurping on the rights of others and
on a daily basis
has targeted the people of palestine
lebanon and most
recently even iraq as well as syria
no there is no terrorism throughout the
world that matches
the activities of israel that has
been seeking for the past 71 years since
its inception
since its founding so those who
fight for the freedom of their lands and
their homes are not terrorists
those are terrorists who render aid to
daesh to isis
israel is the country that takes care of
the injured
isis and they make weapons available to
them so daesh isis are the terrorists
israel
supports isis
certainly undoubtedly do you have any
doubts would you like to see
the proof you should visit israeli
hospitals
and see the injured isis war fighters
how they're being taken care of you
should see the weapons
captured from isis fighters and see that
there are israeli made
the challenge is that sometimes american
media outlets fail to reveal the truth
to the american public
and you they they only receive the news
from one specific
viewpoint or channel if you will so
that's why the people of america are
quite
frankly not very well aware of the
realities
in our region if the american people
were to know
that so many yemenis on a daily basis
with their money and their weapon
systems are being innocently killed and
their lives taken away they would not
stay silent
since president trump pulled out of the
nuclear deal
last year iran has now taken steps
to violate the agreement themselves
you have broken the limits on
enriching uranium on stockpiles of
enriched uranium
and now you're using advanced
centrifuges
if you were a year away from a nuclear
weapon when you signed the iran deal
back in 2015 how much closer
are you to a weapon today with these
steps that you have taken
the construct of your question sir
is one that is based on pre-judgment
uh first of all the
if we were seeking nuclear weapons we
would not have signed on to jjcpoa if we
sought
nuclear weapons we would not have
accepted the additional problems but you
agree that you have
mr wallace uh you are a veteran
uh reporter allow me but today i don't
understand why
in the middle of my responses you are
not giving me
you're not allowing me to complete my
responses allow me to clarify
one thing for everyone allow me to
clarify what we are saying
no country in the world
and the additional protocols
and for someone to accuse them of
seeking nuclear weapons
if they if someone seeks nuclear weapons
why would they
go under the controls of the iaea so
this is not correct
we are not seeking nuclear weapons
the country that has killed japanese
people with nuclear weapons and today
has left the agreement previously signed
with russia for medium-range missiles
and nuclear missiles and against the npt
is today
building nuclear arsenals today that
country is america
iran has lived up to her commitments
and according to those commitments we
see that
the ones who have broken the commitment
is the united states of america and not
iran
have you made a calculation to wait
until
after the 2020 election
and to negotiate to wait and see
if president trump is defeated do you
believe that perhaps mr biden or
another democratic president would be
easier to negotiate with the
better him of hard women for us it
doesn't matter
whether the united states president is a
democrat or a republican
this is the purview and the prerogative
of the united states of america and her
people
of every american whom they wish to
choose
we say that america should live up to
our commitments be the democrat or
republican president
a national commitment the commitment of
a country is not based on a party in
control
of the presidency of the executive
branch so it was
the country the nation that
gave the commitment so we want to see
someone
who will live up to these commitments
takes these commitments seriously
and it is us the islamic republic of
iran
whom today as you mentioned earlier in
one of your
questions we have given the hope
initiative for peace
the hormones peace
initiative
[Music]
that is why we have invited all
countries
in the region to come together so that
we can
reach peace and not allow the flames of
war to continue to be found
what makes a difference and is important
for us is living up to one's
international
commitments
the commitment is something that was
given by the government of the united
states of america so it really doesn't
matter for us our counterparts which
political party they come from
mr president thank you so much for
speaking with us
thank you